Hello, welcome to the Excellent University Virtual Training Symposium. Agilent Korea, which is in charge of today's section, is in charge of
customer workshops and
training.
The 7,800 and 7900
icp-ms devices, which are equipment, will be covered in a wide range of essential theories, technologies,
and maintenance processes
.
Some people have a preconceived notion that icp-ms
is difficult to handle and too complex equipment before using it.
If
so, I have a small hope that through today's training,
icp-ms can become a base that is
more familiar to you, rather than a difficult and complex device.
Today, you will
learn the following concepts through this web or watch. Learn
about the basic principles of icp-ms, including concepts in atoms and ions, and
learn about
the main hardware components of icp-ms.
Then, you will
understand the resident's unique cell technology to understand and eliminate spectral interference, explain the
successful Tune
concept and goals for optimizing your icp-ms system, and
finally, basic maintenance and
Let's take a moment to introduce a guide to problem solving
. So, before we start, what is important
in analytical chemistry, especially inorganic analytical chemistry, such as metals
?
And furthermore, it can be
said that the main purpose is to perform quantitative analysis that does not specify concentration and content. For
this purpose, the catalyst for inorganic analytical
chemistry has been continuously evolving, and
the ability to clearly identify individual components is the most important.  This is important,
and once it is possible to measure it, the
next step is to count it directly
and get the result.
Thus, icp-ms has
all the prerequisites for accomplishing both of these goals,
as well as interfacing
with other technologies such as hplc and gc.
Let's look more
closely
at icp-ms, which is becoming a representative technology for weapon analysis.
Plasma, which has temperature energy,
is used as a medium source.
In addition, it has an amazing sensitivity, that is, it
is possible to firmly quantify the ppb
level.
For example, 1 ppb is
the distance from the earth to the moon.
It is a number that is almost equivalent to identifying and finding a random shoe you have and even calculating its length.
Can you feel a little bit when I explain it like this?
Unlike what has been pursued as a major goal in technology development,
the mass spectrometry technology of Ashikim SS
does not require such high resolution.
Rather, it provides a faster writing and
wide measurement range
, convenient software UI,
and flexibility with various
It would be nice to see that this is a line that is required these days.
Then, let's look at
the structure of an atom, which is the basis
of atomic mass spectrometry. Atomic weight, which is the mass of an atom.
Since the mass of electrons
is very small compared to protons and neutrons
, it has little effect on the original amount,
so the sum of the number of protons and neutrons
becomes the mass number of the atom. In
particular, the number of protons among them
means the unique original number of the element.  And
the number of neutrons is recognized as an element with different atomic weight, that is, it has
the same number of protons, so the
element is
called a different
isotope of the same
subatomic weight.
For example,
the atomic number of beryl is 4, after hydrogen, helium, and
lithium. There are four protons and
five neutrons, so the total mass number is 9. As
a
general rule, the weight of an atom
is indicated by a left superscript.
If an atom, which will be explained on the next slide, is
divorced, it
is represented by a plus sign in the superscript on the right.
Next,
you should also understand the process of becoming atom number 2 or
.
In
particular
, a nuclear power plant exposed to an environment with high-density energy atoms such as plasma
emits one of the free electrons circulating overseas around the nucleus due to high-temperature collisions,
and in this case, a
positive charge is periodically
We call this divorce.
In icp,
the state in which one electron is removed is generally
called a binary state, and in
some atoms, up to a second electron
can be released, in which case it is called a cation.
Since most of is contained in the nucleus,
it is considered to have the same mass as the neutral atom,
because the condition remains
stable until it can recombine with electrons again
.
Thus, these January states in icp-ms
It
is recorded in a spherical environment to maintain
and remains as an ion throughout the final detector case.
Earlier we saw that even neutral atoms in a high-
energy plasma
will emit their outermost electrons
and change into valence ions.
In
other words, the atoms are  It depends on the energy needed to become a soul,
that is,
ionization energy. If
you look at the definition of all elements,
the ion or potential energy of the original document is specified at the bottom left of the element symbol
. For
reference, the chart in the middle is the
periodic table you are familiar with.  By
displaying
Onajeon, most of the group work and group elements are
100% within the icp,
while the
halogen and kill elements in the upper right corner are
less than 1% and 2
are made.
Since more than 80% is won, it
is considered to be completely won, and
if it does not become the original
iWanna, the mass document cannot be seen essentially.
The
table you are looking at now is a distribution map
of helper elements that exist in nature
. The
horizontal axis means the mass unit of each element,
and
by displaying the corresponding element's irbundance under the new column, you can
quickly get help.  The treaty is
useful as an n table.
It also helps to identify interference with potential isobaric elements, i.e.,
enemies that overlap with other enemies. If
you look at beryllium earlier, it means
that beryllium, whose mass number is
spherical, exists as 100% of Earth's obstacles.
However, taking the element company Orn as an
example, there are two elements, Boron
with a mass number of 10 and Boron with a mass number of 11
11.
The number of unknown protons in the element gear 5 is the
same as 5, but
the number of neutrons is different, so the atomic weight is
different.
We call these atoms isotopes,
and
the distribution of the binary numbers is
19.9% ​​and 10.1%, respectively, and the
integration is 100%.
element number 1  8 19 22
Nangon Potassium Calcium is a number with a mass number of
40 and has the same isotope. Since
these cognate elements have the
same mass number as monkeys with completely different chemical properties
, they are actually
detected with the same mass number in a mass spectrometer
.  The icp-ms released by Qilent in Korea
is largely divided
into two models: 7800 and 7900.
Some of the functions are provided as standard,
and the system
can be additionally configured in various ways to suit your purpose. For
reference, the most  A typical configuration is as
follows:
Missing t for the introductory Internet standard
and helium ors function and a configuration with hmi
or uhm ah function
.
You can select additional Otter samples according to the
screen. The sds poto sampler at the bottom of the screen
can hold 4 liquid barrels that can load up to 60 samples, so you can
analyze up to 240 starts in 1 medium at a time.
If you need to process as many as 10 days, such as soil
, you use a lot of 2 auto samplers
.  A tray capable of loading up to 89 samples
can be used. In addition to this, it can be used
in many applications by adding hardware accessories or specific functions that have already
been
verified.  Isis, a system of liquids,
and 6.25 phosphorus or
petrochemicals are also provided by
Olga My Package, which can be analyzed by direct injection of the analyte
.
It enables the separation of arsenic and the sulfur wave
analysis of gasoline.
Then, let's take a look at what the main hardware constituting the actual icp-ms is.
Most of the terms consist of baseball
and a lot of information will be presented,
but the main  As
you can see, the block is not largely five types.
Briefly, the front end is
called sample lint reduction, and
it means a device for introducing liquid samples.
As you know, the source is the part
that creates inductively coupled plasma,
which is the source when forming ions, and in the
4th generation or s,
it supplies helm and surgery to the octopore divorce guide
to cause collisions and reactions between ions,
causing various possible occurrences.  It
is responsible for removing indirect factors in advance.
Then, for the most common scoop, a
mass spectrometer is used in icp-ms,
and
finally,
ions are directly counted through an electronic information key called em.
Specifically, let's look
at the main role from the front end to the plasma interface. The
introduction
part is one of the most important parts of icp-ms. A
well-designed sample introduction part helps to
achieve good analysis results and reduce maintenance bond time
The main purpose of the
nebulizer is to spray the liquid sample in the form of a small high-
efficiency aerosol, that is, mist, and
send it well to the center of the plasma.
Through the argon plasma of the temperature,
positive ions are formed from the
aerosols. In
order to secure good results from the aerosols of a complex or easily deteriorated matrix, the
plasma
can maintain a high 225°C temperature.
Then, in
order to extract the ionized elements, an interface gap
consisting of two conical metal plates with
a small inner diameter is formed, and the
plasma and vacuum are connected to each other
by lowering the pressure by about 1mm from atmospheric pressure.
The ions expand into the interface
and enter the
interface. The ions that have passed through the plasma interface
then pass through the ORS, a corridor polyreaction system, which is a resident's own technology that plays a role in the next furnace.
The
iron beam passes through the central axis of the or s cell
and
is trapped in the lower field created by the octopal rod,
and through the fitting at the top, the selks that fly through the fitting
flow into the inside of the or s
The design of this or s is a technology called collision
web sun cell, also called rc,
which plays a role in removing ions in the spectrum room.
Since the 1990s,
the performance of Edilent's crc technology has been sufficiently proven,
and has been
sold since the 2000s  Most
elon tip msn's are equipped with this technology.
So
what does spectral interference interfere with
in icp-ms?  Interferences in the form of overlapping identically on the peaks that can have
a large impact on accurate measurement of the analyte
mainly occur, and
physical interferences that do not affect other analytes mainly occur. For
example, the same mass as other elements
Cognate elements directly superimposed by
isotopes, for example
114 card hate and
tin, which have the same isotope, can be misheard, and
also isobaric interference from nearby species can also cause a mass spectrometer to make a kerb drop.
Since the members are unfavorable on the basis of electrification and b,
interference between
sources may occur if a peak
with the second electron removed is detected.  Again,
your trim and zircon 90
will affect both.
However, the interferences of these chromosome species are
easy to predict and can usually be
avoided by selecting the appropriate isotopes of the chromosome
.
Also, the same ion  Although it changes the shape of the
plasma gas
, exposed ions of various matrices such as psychics
are bonded to the sputum. Multiatomic interference also
causes representative spectral interference.
Molecular multiatomic interference is argon.
In addition to forming some amazing polyatoms, such as oxygen,
they interfere with each other as they form various people.
These icp-ms interferences can often have very
small effects, but
the fact that they measure minute concentrations and the fact that they are in a hurry
can have a much larger effect.  The most common way
to avoid the preceding physical spectral interference is
to select isotopes that do not interfere with each other
between the analytes
.  Alternatively
, it can be the most common means of dealing with spectral customs, but
since diluting the component
also proportionally reduces the signal of the component, the
market alone is limited.
Therefore, this polyatomic interference is
different.  It is possible to effectively reduce interference by lowering the oxide ray shawl through hmr technology, which is a unique technology,
but the lee
entity 4th generation ors cell technology, which will be explained this time, can remove
and manage spectrum
interference most efficiently and toward the source regardless of the previous processing process.
there is  It can be said that it is a technology that
can kill interference through the collision-induced Hery mechanism
using helium gas, which is a representative method.
This
is a process that is not involved in the reaction, so
no new polyatoms are created.
As shown in the figure, the collision-induced
Hery mechanism is coupled with each other.  The polyatomic
ions
collide with the light trailing helium filled in the ors cell
to destroy and dissociate the polyatomic bonds with water, so that the original
monoatomic ion is maintained again. By the
helium abundance method described above
,  Even if the atoms are not harmed, they are heated.
Due to the physical size of the atoms, called
cross-sections, the number of collisions with helium gas increases more than that of monatomic analytes with stepwise smaller cross-sections.
Boda atoms collide with helium several times
and lose more energy in
this process. After going through this process,
the kinetic energy of the members becomes different from each other,
and we name this as someone else's tick
energy disk imitation,
and  As shown in the figure, the
fore pole bias is rotated more positively than the octopole bias
to give a differential voltage so that the difference in kinetic
energy
can be determined.
That is, due to frequent collisions with members with lower energy than the energy to cross this energy hill, that is
, with
helm, the
kinetic energy is lowered, and polyatoms
cannot climb this hill, and
through this, polyatomic indirection is eliminated
Next,
let's look at the function of the quadro
pole
matsan riser, called quad for short.  china  It is composed of a ruler shape
and the material is very good in electrical conductivity.
Molly bags are always used
. If Dylan tip ms prides itself on one thing,
it
has been downsizing by more than 30% each time over the past decade while continuously launching new models,
but it has never been a quad  The size of the egi has
not been reduced, but has been maintained, and the technology has been developed by
increasing the path of the entire ion by about 30 mm
.
Direct current and alternating current voltages are applied to each of the placed
rods.
For example, for ions of mass m,
there is a setting value for direct current and alternating current voltage to create a stable open contact in the quad.
By applying this, even if all masses come in
,
Many elements of the set mass number selected in the quad
remain, and members lower or higher than this
are introduced while drawing an unstable orbit,
and eventually
removed by vacuum by being separated from the rod
.
Therefore, one mass is collected at a time, and the
rest  is lossy, so the term mesh filter
is used. For reference, the 7807
Heaven's Eye
has a data acquisition rate that can scan the entire mass spectrum in about 0.1 second, 10 times per second in the case of a 12 ms quadropole mass filter.
At the same time as the cut pole plays a role as a mass filter, the performance of this filter is also
expressed as a decomposition norm in the mass peak
.
The resolution of these mesh peaks is
inversely proportional to the prophecy speed required by the rf frequency applied to the quadro forane and the length of the pole rod as cut. The width seen
in the mass peak at the bottom of the actual slide,
especially
the superposition value at the 10% position from the total peak height.  Let the quad
judge the resolution  A
typical setup for system damage is to resolve the peaks only
to the points needed to separate them with adjacent mass velcros,
and
these units are called resolutions, and produce
peaks narrowed to about 0.7 milky-wide.
The
actual mass value is recognized as a mass value by arranging and matching each other through
the caliber provided by the software
called msx.
This is the central point of the ms peak, which is matched with the
brass -0.1 grace value in the actual atomic ms value. For
reference, the x cis, which is the peak in every spectrum,
means the mass value and the
chromatographic growth time, so
do not confuse them with each other.
Most of the detectors used in icp-ms, which is the last of the major hardware configurations, use electron amplification units
that provide high sensitivity and low background values.
The first one arrives at
this node. The same 3 premises are emitted as much as the number of prophecies reached by this node
, and the
second one is emitted from this node by a multiple of 2
to amplify the signal. Signals up to
8 of 10  The
actual divorce counter is amplified up to 10 out of 11
elimination
, which means it has a wide linear dynamic measurement range, which is an important part of the detection dog performance.
When a
signal high enough to be overlens is detected, for example, a
count of more than the 6th crest of 10 is
detected
, the analog output, which is the middle terminal, is made to detect multiple signals to protect em,
and the pulse hv
terminal is automatically closed.
Normally, the analog terminal  In highball
Taejin is a bolt up to as many as 3 classes
and  The pulse is within plus 2000 volts
,
and the
diode voltage is periodically re-adjusted
through auto-tuning for optimization of
the em detector.
In addition, in order to maintain high sensitivity and low background value,
it is
recommended that the r
riser part where the Yen detector is located always maintain
a stable high
vacuum condition.  I would like to explain how to optimize the system through actual tuning.
Unfortunately, ms can optimize the system
several times according to the relatively simple
and
automatic guard sequence.
First of all, let's look at startup hardware settings.
The startup function optimizes the system based on
the initial conditions in the factory, which has already been widely applied,
and verifies the overall performance of the machine.
This means that the Plasma Zerta can always optimize the system several times
by performing the start-up function at the same time. A
total of 8 hardware functions can
be executed.
It is also possible to perform only the tasks selected by checking the checkbox.
Second, there is
a method of optimizing the system through 4 t of batches to be analyzed. The
most widely used
method for batch tuning is to use Auto Team
or
Tuning is usually a routine process
and operators experienced with icp-ms will
spend more time tuning once they get used to it.
Then,
what are the prerequisites for successful tuning?
First of all, you need a mince solution and a tuning
solution
.
This is because successful tuning can never be expected without the introduction of cerium oxide.
And the so-called robust
layer condition is mainly used in applications that use water-soluble solvents. It
minimizes the critical level of cerium oxide generated during the analysis process.
By reducing the interference between various sample matrices as much as possible
, it can help to obtain the signal sensitivity of the runcer more stably.
I will explain a little more about the tuning solution used in . The
solution for basic tuning contains 5 elements
such as lithium, cobalt, thallium, etc.
Generally, 1 ppb tuning solution is
the most used and cpm tuning
sound.  You can purchase and dilute it to the desired concentration. In
particular, among the five elements, metium,
yttrium, and thallium are
used to check the mechanical response of each for the low and middle mass ranges,
and cobalt is tuned to helm or hydrogen, etc.
or s mode
Finally, cerium, which has a mass number of 140, is used
to check the human level and the double charge ratio. For
reference, the tuning brush comes
with the purchase of the 7800 and 7900 systems by default
.
Once opened and used,  Seal well
and store at room temperature. The
exact concentration is not important, but manage it
carefully to avoid contamination.
In addition, the expiration date is specified on the container label,
so please use it within the period.
How can you judge an optimized system after successful
qing  Divided by this time, the
count bus second immediately ps is
used as the basis for the patient column unit.
Then again, the unit concentration is
generally regarded as cps per 1 ppb and
is used as an indicator of the current machine sensitivity.
Second, the precision of the signal is judged.
The stability and precision of the signal is that
the percentage rsd of the representative relative label deviation can also be
interpreted, and the current percentage rsd can be obtained through repeated collection
of unit
concentration unit counts in 0.1 second units of the reference element included before this Turing number
.  In
the process of actually tuning the device,
the sensitivity of the three representative elements mentioned above
is adjusted to the iron level response curve, and No. 49
, which is an indicator of medium true perfume,
has the highest trim and No. 205
with the highest line positive
number.
The sensitivity of No. 7 and 2 teams, which have a particularly low mass number, should be
tuned lower than
this, and at the same time, the
oxide rate should be minimized.
In addition to this
, the gas in the nebulizer can be effectively controlled using both iran and hmi and
ors functions. For
example, the advanced oxide lacey is
combined with the refined oxide of 140 to
create a new one.
By calculating the ratio of cerium and cerium,
it is possible to predict how compatible the current system is.
Through this, lowering the oxide ratio
is one of the main tuning goals,
and if the value is high, the
system  This
means that a lot of other metals are also being generated within
the element. This will cause poor results in the recovery procedure for that element,
which will also affect the analysis results.
The proxy tuning method, which can predict the same result even for the material, is widely used in the process
of optimizing the icp-ms system
. Looking at the current time, 30 minutes have already
passed
.  I'll
explain about it. If
you want to keep your Ash pms well
, the first
thing to do is to use a lot of materials around you that contain basic and detailed information.
Mass Hunter 4, a representative icp-ms program
Help function You can find the information you need at any time through the video
materials and main truss video dvd
and 7800 7900 user
manual disc on this farm
.
For maintenance,
refer to
the emf key plus feedback function provided within the Maesunda program that is used every day
. Double-click emf in the status view window located at the top right of the screen you are viewing, or
You can also access it through
emf, in simple words, you can think of it as a clock timer inside the base
.  The timer bar will turn red when the
set target time for a required major component is approaching
or has elapsed,
in which case a notification message will always
appear whenever the software is started or the plasma is
turned on.  It is very useful for
tracking and managing maintenance without missing the timing by notifying the user when the tax is legal
.
Of course, the maintenance interval can be adjusted according to the user environment,
and the
user can directly
add and manage the desired item to the emf.
Next, there is also a maintenance log function.
Like mf, it
can be selected from the menu in the hardware maple, and this
is a function that saves maintenance operations performed by the user in
the form of electronic records
. As maintenance, the function is saved by date.
stamps
such as date and time when maintenance was performed
can be added, representative
maintenance items and off rates performed
can be identified, and additional comments can be
provided to provide more detailed information, etc.
So far, when I have been in the field and
met various customers, many of them always
ask a lot about the maintenance cycle
for pms.  There is no definitive answer,
i.e. each of you will be determined by the
environment, application and amount of analysis in your different laboratory
.
So it is of utmost importance that you, like
you, establish your own maintenance intervals tailored to your environment.
How is this possible?
It is very
important to use
sources such as emf, performance reports, and maintenance log records described above, and to make separate notes whenever major hardware changes or maintenance work becomes easy.  In
addition to the work process, we ask that you set up your own optimized maintenance cycle through the maintenance boss guide for major components that will be explained in the future.
This is a very good practice for your laboratory operation
and
one of the quick troubleshooting  middle
So, before rejuvenating the plasma,
let
's look at the situation that you should always
check every day based on the following
checklist.
Check
the emf part marked in red and
take action if necessary, and check
the location of the rinse solution and trin solution. Then, check that
the teabing connected to the peristaltic pump is
properly hung and there is no abnormality
Also
, make sure that there are no other residues in the spray chamber and the connection of the collector Watteau sieve, which is a component made of glass
.
In addition, operate the chiller, which is a water circulation device,
and empty the drain container.
Green Other
safety rules in your laboratory  and internal regulations for maintaining the environment are
also complied with and adhered to. In
the process of daily checking, the
maintenance of the Xido Island 2 is very important
.  Because about 80 percent
of the problems in this area become medicine. The
concept is very simple. Supplying a
stable and constant amount of liquid and
generating an efficient n air load are
the most basic and important factors for successfully operating ICP-MS
.  This is because
the main maintenance items that make up the sample inlet
have slightly different management methods depending on the
material.  Most
of the
typical polymer
teabing is located at the entrance of Shodo,
and Jeju National University components such as Tigon pvc ptfe
are basically
recommended to be replaced rather than washed
.
It is full tubing and internet
elementary schooling.
This less teabing is
the pump teabing that is directly connected to the peristaltic pump, so
you need to pay the most attention
.  For
reference, in the case of 3 teabing, if you hold it with both hands
, it looks flat without a curve, but
teabing that has been used for a long time
is easily twisted when pressed or twisted.
Visually check if there is any part, and if there
is a leak or
if there is a problem such as game phenomenon or clogging in
the peristaltic pump, replace the tubing immediately.
Touch collector spray chamber and
nebulizer are typical. The
most common cleaning method is
to use a dedicated detergent or
soak it in a container with a cup for a long time.
Citran corn is used as a representative detergent, and it has
a concentration of about 2% per area.
If it is difficult to purchase, it is
diluted to about 5% and used for cleaning for the 7-year-old
you have.  In this case, it
is better to use acid cleaning and painful cleaning methods
together.
One thing to note here is that
in order to increase the effect of the three
chucks, there are cases where ultrasonic cleaning is performed while still in the container.
And, after washing with detergent or tea
, be sure to rinse with pure water
and dry the ends
.  There are cases where there is no gas around the medicine, or
5 minutes or other drying feasts are used for faster drying.
Never use these buns as they may cause
unexpected contamination. Finally, in the case of nebulizers,
generally  Maintenance is not required
,
but if it is clogged or the treatment
does not work properly, you can clean it more conveniently by not going to the house for a long time as above
or using it as a nebulizer clean
although it is not on the slide now.
Let's look at the maintenance method.
Typical examples are the shield plate, the sample
cone, and the ion lens.
Rather than directly polishing and removing these metal components, we
first proceed with cleaning contaminated items that are adsorbed or buried on the surface.
This is  A simple rinse
may have a great effect, but
if not,
a little physical cleaning using a cleaner or abrasive
may be more effective. In
the case of the shield plate, in
the process of disassembling and assembling the torch rather than the book due to contamination
In most cases, it is difficult to maintain the original function because the surface is wrinkled or damaged
by sparks caused by remaining water in the touch,
so if
this situation occurs, it
is recommended to replace it immediately.
In the environment,
mixing may be required between batches, and
performance may be deteriorated depending on minute matches or matrices,
so periodic maintenance and
cleaning is required. For
reference, the performance of the cone is
judged by visually inspecting the ear piece at the tip.  You can do it.
The photo on the top right means the orifice in a normal cone,
and if
it goes right below or
is clogged with the accumulation of relics,
the performance of the cone deteriorates, which can cause biliary tract, reproducibility,
and vacuum part,
so carefully manage  Let the
degree of uphill  3 packs of severe cones
are washed by diluting acid or Cytranox,
but there is no such evil site with 2%
or if you use a time difference, you can use the real ni
percent
.
It is known how to manage, check, and
clean.
1 It's hard to remember everything.
Don't worry
. The disassembly and cleaning methods for all the components I've described
are
explained in detail on the maintenance video DVD provided to you,
so please refer to it anytime you need it.
Even if you are doing good maintenance, unexpected damage or breakdown,
especially the introduction and interface parts,
are mostly composed of consumables.
100 It is recommended to have a shoulder frame.
Therefore,
if you find an abnormality in the part during the maintenance process, first
wash it first, and
if the symptom still does not improve
, replace the real replacement with the consumables you have as a backup
to quickly solve the problem.
It is recommended.
Of course, if you do not remember well for checking and replacing the part,
please refer to the maintenance video DVD first before starting the work.
Testing
can be more helpful in solving the cause of the problem.
Also, these days, you can easily take pictures or videos with your mobile phone
, so if
you take a picture of the parts in advance before
disassembling it, it can be very
helpful for the entrance exam for the first time.  If you need to disassemble a complicated part or
disassemble and assemble a part you have never experienced before,
use the above method a lot.
If necessary,
don't
forget to leave
a record of
maintenance in the
afternoon and manage it.
W Did it help you a lot? In
fact, the unfortunate
part of applying the pms device directly is that even if you experience problems yourself
in the process of using the device in the future
, if you make good use
of the tools and guides around you and what you have learned today
There is a
little time left. Please let me know if you have any
questions or concerns about the contents covered so far. I
will
give you
additional answers and
wrap up today's session.  Thank you for participating in the 4g Eme Item SB 20 course, which is a corpse that will make you want to be able to sen.
Did you watch the previous video?
I will do it next, and now the
content of boiled water is appearing on the screen. A
total of 4 doors, no, I am going to go out.
Please participate in the survey.
I'm coming.
I'll
give you that custunt wen
, but it can also be used by adapters,
but often 6 solvents are directly injected and
analyzed, or nanoparticles are applied,
and ash or instructions and my
mouth  It
is also used in such 8-plate technology as before Gia Blaze. If I
dare to compare it with
Auto Gum, the individual tuning person for the custom version
was the same.
It
means that it
is not dealt with. Then, Byeong-cheol Cho is the second question
. Tell me more about how to clean the sampling cone.
I have a
question. I would like an
answer
.
As for the same Jeon Venus, it is recommended
to soak it in clean water first, and if you
have it around, use the insurance to
clean the inside and outside of the corrector and then wash
it
well with clean
water.  Even if you soak the fishing gear, you
can wash it from the beginning of about 5 to 15 minutes.
Well, Softly's method like this
is used the most
.
In this case
, use a little branch and soak the kernels in
about 5% fish solution, if not 4 fish
water,
take out with a cotton swab of the same rack as above and
wipe the outside and inside well
for about 5 minutes for about 5 minutes.
Proceed to the extent of throwing
it away. Then,
wash the green barley
again with clean water. Uh, and then soak it in clean water again
for about 5 minutes
.  It's good, but
one thing to note here
is that you don't wear 5 sets of 2 bumpers for a long time while holding a man's cone.
And because you can back down, if you become
this handsome
, rather  I like the president of
Kwon so please
feel sorry for me because
I can bring it.
A more representative syrup that changes the form of an aerosol is
also a device at the
mouth. My blaze, which is generally used for 7800 and 7900 icp-ms,
is of
the type of concept.
By designing the paddle
, the hat is introduced to the inside, which is formed
by a very high ka stream, and the
parallel tail is introduced.  In
the case of this design in the form of a van treatment, the lowered pressure in the
passage narrowed at the end is sucked up quickly
toward the narrow passage due to the difference between the pressure and the pressure caused by the previous high car stream
.
Yes, and the next question is,
should I use the sample cone or skimmer bowl separately when using hydrofluoric acid
? I have always accepted 6
Solvents are used separately.
4 It's
a little bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of
a bit of  If you use this or something like that, you
need to use a different material opt
affinity
bt skimmer conditioner yesterday
.
Also, as you explained and inquired a while ago, in
the case of Confucianism, fish oil rhinitis
, touch a fairly clean Matty Jihwajeong.  go because you can give  If you change it to
opt corner bt cone today, rather than this book, Nike
Kun, you can get much better performance
.  The acid is
contained within 10% of the acid inside, so in the
matrix, you
should see what you need to do with the cone-based Affleck rods and skis.
If you do, in that case,
you can feel it by using the Pizza
Bracon in , and in some cases, you may use it in a dirty station.
Please,
and the next question is when using hydrofluoric acid
, should I use mid gas with 2 organic solvents or can
I just use authorized water only?
I have to go
uh short 4 this and
the reason why I have to use this value is that it is
based on 6 auctions and it is often made of partial
carbon
So,
as I rode it, now that I am, these things can stick
in 9 minutes or
lower the severe cooldown.
The carbons are now made to be shorted with fish clothes,
so
that
they
can be made
Siwa.  It's just a handwriting, but when it's
ridiculous or  3 Yano breasts without using gas Did you do the
character?
Rotation can now see the on-
demand raw son. If you
click on it once in the menu, you can
look
at the information on the software related to the mass spectrometer if it is low in accent chromatography. If
you
leave us a
question, our specialist in charge will answer
Also, there is an explanation of the lobby. If
you fill it out, it
will be very helpful when I plan an event like this in the
future.
Investment Com also operates live chat
counseling. If you have any
questions you want to ask the agent, if
you use the book-based counseling, you
will be able to answer more quickly.
Two
lectures are being conducted live or recorded in
Korean, English and Thai.
And the
hbs course will be conducted in Korean at 10:00 on February 25th
.
If you don't have this, I'll greet you
today with this. Thank you, our 2021 Cosmology Master
, for participating in the Multi-Birch Regression Symposium
today.
Law Juggler Well